Warren Buffett invested in so many
one-town newspapers because they were
monopolies there wasn't enough room for
another paper to come in town and a
newspaper had two monetization things
which may never be available again cable
TV had the same thing people would have
access to the content and advertisers
would pay to have access to the eyeballs
they got paid on both sides and people
became exorbitantly wealthy the thing is
is that digital media eroded that first
sale to the customer which is when
Facebook came in and said it's free and
it always will be they stuck with that
because they realized because it was
free they were able to gobble up so much
more media their cost to acquire
eyeballs at a platform level was so low
that it made more sense for them to not
try and monetize the audience except
through the advertising it took me way
too long to realize that the game had
changed fundamentally in terms of how
media is monetized and how media can
grow a brand and the amount of reach
that a single video a single bout of
effort can deliver